[Music]
did you do mushrooms there was a story i
heard once that you did mushrooms
with well well like i say with woody
harrelson and george went that you
actually did mushrooms with them and
let's just talk about it why not it's
been a long time the statute of
limitations has passed you're right
it's not true
shoot i blanked first and i okay it's
true
i'm gonna let you go but like
an absolute idiot i ruined what i hear
could have been a nice experience
um don't do don't don't don't anyone i
i'm so old no kid will do what i'm doing
so this is actually
an anti-drug thing statement because
you know young people don't want to do
it anyway um
you're saying learn from your mistakes
yes i am and don't get on a boat
we uh what we decided to uh tell the
whole story what happened here well we
we decided to play hooky
um and so all the boys got on uh
john uh ratzenberger's boat and we went
out to catalina
and and you called in sick at cheers yes
and i think then we actually did even
light up and uh so
we're in the harbor i hadn't had any
breakfast i have the munchies
and woody says have you ever tried
mushrooms and i go
no what a great i have a free day i'm on
a
boat no one i will be called upon by
nobody
yeah no one i i'm not responsible for
anything today how wonderful
yes and you know what i'm hungry aren't
i
i'm so angry so
i ate way more than my share and for the
next three hours i
died i you know i
i i i would forget to breathe and george
you would forget to breathe
literally george went with would who was
so bored that i had done this he didn't
do it it was just me and woody
he'd look at me and go breathe
but he had to say it like 60.